but
the really big story this week the fbi
raided mar-a-lago i'm sure you saw that
uh
well
apparently
i find this hard to believe but
apparently donald trump was up to no
good i don't know how it happened
but they say the fbi was tipped off by
someone very close to him so uh that
eliminates melania but
but yeah went into his home for nine
hours of course republicans reacted like
they do in karachi when someone burns a
koran
karachi's in pakistan sorry i thought
you knew that
yes the holy man donald trump was
insulted so now all across the
right-wing media it's war they're
literally using this word civil war war
there's a right-wing podcaster i think
the name of stephen crowder said sleep
well
tomorrow is war
and then tomorrow came and there was no
war
unless by war he means more podcasting
yeah war
war there's a dozen people protesting
mega people outside of
mar-a-lago that was their war the first
battalion of the maga brigade
based out of fort starbucks
[Applause]
trump put out a statement my beautiful
home is under siege
even lindsey graham was like girl relax
they waited till you weren't home they
went and they got some of your old boxes
it wasn't so much of a raid as a bad
breakup
and
but even though this is about some
they're saying now the washington post
says today about nuclear
information that shouldn't be out there
that trump has trump supporters like no
this is politically motivated they say
if you lock him up
how are we going to lock her up
and oliver like fox nation this is their
big thing if they can do this to trump
they can do it to you that's right
average american
think twice before you leave the white
house with classified nuclear
information
but you know some
somebody has to tell these people this
is actually how the system is supposed
to work you know like when you watch
criminal minds
it's like that except real
if you do something wrong joe montana
puts it in jail it's one of the reasons
i've never staged a coup
but i think this is what they really
were upset about they got into a safe
they have this say they and the faith
interesting trump's safe you get into it
by facial recognition
luckily one of them had a rotting
jack-o-lantern
but here's here's the exciting thing
they got into a safe and we got the
contents they're on the way here tonight
we're going to open them right here on
the show
i don't know how they did it
yeah
we're going to see it together for the
first time i'm very excited it should be
here in about i don't know 20 minutes
depending on how the panel's doing
[Laughter]
anyway trump had a really terrible week
not just did that happen to him he had
to testify in new york about his
business empire which is a little shady
i hear
he took the fifth
440 times and after that he posted this
statement he said you know i once said
if you're innocent why are you pleading
the fifth now i know
yeah
i know too because you're [ __ ] guilty
that's why
you